well to help keep a handle on the spread
of covid here in the valley immunized
nevada
is doubling down on vaccination efforts
this weekend it's partnering with mgn
resorts to offer entertainment prizes
to those who get the vaccine hector
mejia is live on the las vegas strip
with the details hector good afternoon
hey there well we've heard about the
nevada cash prizes before but how about
some
concert and sporting tickets or flight
in hotel packages that's exactly what
mgm resorts is offering at a pop-up
clinic
setting up tomorrow here on the las
vegas strip specifically at park
mgm to boost the vaccination numbers
currently fewer than 55 percent of
nevadans 12 and older
have started the vaccination process
those who get the coronavirus vaccine
tomorrow will be entered in the raffle
and here's what mgm resorts is offering
a vegas football package which includes
flights to las vegas
plus a two night stay in a fancy suite
at mandalay bay
a boxing package with flights boxing
tickets and a sweet hotel stay
maluma and bruno mars concert packages
also with hotel stays
this is all in partnership with
immunized nevada the pop-up clinic will
also offer
testing and live entertainment it's open
to anyone ages 12 and up who still has
not received
their vaccine i want to help you from
the worst possible outcome you should
definitely do it in packages incentives
are good
and if there's the money to do it why
not honestly i think it's something that
could work
just because it's like it's vegas you
know people are out here to have a good
time
so that would encourage you to go get
the vaccine yeah definitely i think it
would encourage me and i think it would
encourage a lot of people
all right if you're interested here's
the information you can find the pop-up
clinic this saturday from 10 a.m to 6
p.m again it's at park mgm next to italy
the services are free for anyone ages 12
and older you can just walk in
no idea proof of insurance will be
required and it's also open to locals
you can park over
at new york new york and find parking
there parking for locals is free for a
couple of hours
reporting from the las vegas strip
hector mejia 8 news now